this episode is sponsored by Squarespace
go to squarespace.com microcosmos to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
[Music]
A lot happened in the year 2022
economies shifted rains ended Wars began
so it is okay if you missed out on this
little bit of we think very important
news Demodex have buttholes
now perhaps you have never thought to
wonder about this perhaps you have never
even heard of a Demodex before and
you're just slowly putting together that
it must be related to the creature that
we are watching right now yeah the one
that looks like a tardigrade but weirder
which says a lot given the tardigrades
already look pretty weird to us so you
might wonder why am I supposed to care
if a Demodex has a butthole or not well
we care because they live on our faces
[Music]
demidex are A genus of Tiny Mites that
build their lives around the hair
follicles of various animals and there
are two species that are found on humans
dematex follicularum and Demodex brevis
they each have their own preferred Nooks
on our faces with dematex follicularum
preferring hair follicles and demidex
brevis referring our subcutaneous glands
the mites we are looking at had the
distinction of coming straight from the
face of our master of microscopes James
who saw a little black dot on his
forehead and was curious what was going
on inside so he simply scraped the spot
with the side of a microscope slide and
took a look but these mites don't always
localize themselves in neat little dots
so sometimes scientists have to turn to
other measures to study them in one NPR
interview a scientist described applying
glue to a microscope slide and then
sticking it to a person's forehead so as
they peeled the slide off the mites
would peel off too and look we get it
learning that there are little animals
crawling around on your face it might be
a little unsettling even James who
spends just about every day thinking
about microbes found himself initially
repulsed by what he found on his skin
but then he realized that they look like
tardigrades with big butts and if we can
all collectively love tardigrades the
way that we seem to perhaps we can find
some space in our hearts or these little
mites they're even cute under the harsh
glare of our UV light thank you
the mites are tiny less than a
millimeter in length and you can see two
distinct halves to their body at one end
the tardigrade end as we like to call it
in a purely unscientific way are eight
stubby legs waving behind the demidex's
mouth at the other end are their
gastrointestinal organs and their
genitals those spherical droplets in
their body are oil droplets the digested
remains of the sebum and moisturizer
that Demodex like to eat from our skin
now if at this moment your mind is
Conjuring up images of the Demodex
wandering your face in search of oil to
eat you can rest easy Well for now at
least they're probably not wandering
they're just chilling out inside your
pores at night though Demodex do like to
party they emerge from your pores in
search of each other looking for other
mites to mate with and when they are
done they head back to your pores to lay
their eggs
an adult demidex follicularum lays about
20 to 24 eggs in your hair follicles
within three to four days the young
Demodex will hatch emerging with only
six legs weirdly enough as they develop
into adulthood the other two legs will
develop as well their lifespan will end
a few weeks later at which point the
dead mites will decompose in your
follicles or sebaceous glands turning
the tiny pockets of your skin into
little Mite graveyards
it's a lot I know we keep trying to say
that Demodex are cute actually but then
we talk about little mating parties and
might graveyards on your skin and none
of that is cute but here's the thing we
pretty much all have them if you're
watching this video you probably have
demidex living on your face and if you
don't now you will eventually now they
usually spread through physical contact
though a 2015 study found that we tend
to primarily pass them on Via close
contact with our family members rather
than strangers and when they have found
your face they'll probably stick around
hiding in your pores and other spaces
that make them hard to scrub out
generally that's fine demidex don't
wreak much havoc on your skin they can
become too abundant creating a
distinctive white Sheen that
dermatologists call demodectic Frost not
excess of mites is usually connected to
a decline in the immune system but these
cases are very rare for a time there was
a theory that Demodex could cause
rosacea because they were thought to not
have a butthole what are those things
have in common with each other well the
idea was that without an anus the
Demodex couldn't poop instead the
Demodex would spend their short lives
accumulating waste in large cells in
their body and storing it away and when
they died a feces would burst from their
bodies releasing bacteria that could
then cause rosacea there are enough
correlations between Demodex and the
occurrence of rosacea to leave us
considering that there could be a
connection between the two but we are
here to vindicate the mites a little
because that mechanism is based on an
idea that would turn out to be very
wrong the idea that Demodex don't have
an anus in 2022 scientists were studying
the genes within Demodex and among their
results are some microscopy images and
these words which we hope will become a
classic in the history of butthole
science
there have been several reports that
Demodex does not have an anus and when
Demodex dies the accumulated waste
spills into the pores of the skin and
leads to inflammation this is not
correct
we've talked before about just how
mysterious and confusing the history of
anus evolution is and so we were excited
to hear this news but the other results
of the scientists genetic study of the
Demodex are also worth learning more
about because they reveal just how
strange our relationship with these
creatures is in particular the
scientists found that the Demodex are
surprisingly simple relying on a small
number of proteins to survive this
likely drives their nocturnal Behavior
because they lack the compounds that
allow their relatives to survive at all
in the daytime and this might be the
result of just how lonely the Demodex
mites are in an ecosystem built out of
our skin where they face very few
threats and very little competition
they're doing so well that they may
require less than they once did to
survive
and that has been pushing them at least
according to these scientists to a
future where they might be symbiones
with us much like bacterial
endosymbiones that have become fully
embedded in their hosts that is for now
just a hypothesis if there comes a day
when the hypothesis is fulfilled what do
we do then do we consider them weird and
creepy and maybe even a little rude or
do we accept them as part of us as
inevitable as every other cell in our
body or perhaps it is both as nuanced as
any other experience we have with our
bodies wonderful and terrible all at
once
[Music]
foreign
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring this episode
Squarespace gives people a powerful and
beautiful online platform from which to
create their website so whether you're
looking to create an online portfolio
start a blog or open an online store
Squarespace can help you out maybe it's
finally time to start that podcast
you've been thinking about well you can
use a Blog Page to publish and Syndicate
your podcast with Squarespace you can
even use the Squarespace blog to create
an RSS feed so listeners can use their
preferred podcast service to subscribe
and download new episodes and they make
it super simple to categorize schedule
and share those blog posts as well
Squarespace also makes it easy to keep
in touch with your listeners you can
interact with your community on your
Squarespace site through threaded
comments and replies and generate extra
Revenue through members only content
also if you decide you want to start
selling some merch to go along with that
podcast it's Squarespace is a powerful
e-commerce platform and you can even go
the extra mile and add third-party
extensions to help you manage inventory
streamline bookkeeping and ship products
around the world and you can do all of
this on one easy to use platform so go
to squarespace.com to sign up for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com microcosmos to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or domain
one thing that you've got to know as a
patreon patron of Journey to the
microcosmos is you don't know where the
next episode is going but you trust us
to go in the direction that we want to
go in to discover what we can discover
by not looking big but looking small the
people on the screen right now they are
our patreon patrons another reason that
we can do this if you would like to join
them you can go to patreon.com journey
to micro if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
check out jam and germs on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
thank you
foreign